Somehow or another make it seem like
they would advance in the company more if
they played along. Could be,
yeah, I'm not going to do it
because it feels so good. Yes,
yes. Well you should encourage it,
but I almost feel like, um, yeah,
but you don't want to shame people.
Like there's some brilliant people that
don't work out at all. They're brilliant,
but they just, whatever, for whatever
reason, that's their choice and you know,
it should be your choice to go
out like Christopher Hitchens,
it just fucking drink every day and smoke
cigarettes and one day you get cancer
and you're like, well, you
know, I mean this is like,
he mean he, the way he described it,
like burning the candle at both ends,
it gave a a beautiful,
brilliant light. Yeah.
He wouldn't have had those ideas
if he had done in another way.
It's very possible. That's true.
Most of the madness that we see in,
in brilliant artists, like it's very,
it's very possible that that man,
this would not be expressed if
they had their shit together.
There was something that Sam Harris was
saying the other day on your show just
about about the free well
stuff and I think that it,
that connects to this
information theory kind of thing.
So if we're just sort of a conglomerate
of these actions and words like flowing
the, the actions through
our body and unique ways.
I mean do you accept his
theory on freewill? Um,
well it's not his theory or
it's a conventional theory
of determinism that a lot
of people are, I'm embracing and I think
there's definitely some merit to it.
However,
you and I both know that you choose
whether or not you decide to do something
right. You choose whether or
not you do. Like someone says,
someone says something to you that's
kind of Shitty and you choose whether you
decide to email them
back something shitty.
Like you have that initial impulse
like, well, hey man, fuck you.
You have that initial impulse.
You think on it, you sleep on it.
But why are you thinking
on it and sleeping on it?
Are you doing that because of determinism?
Are you doing that because you're
trying to be a better person and are you
trying to be a better person because of
all the factors that played out in your
life? Like environment, Jean's
life experience, all those things,
right. It means it's really good.
It's a really good discussion.
So do you own the words that you're
saying right now? It's a good question.
Larry Lessig, who's on
here the other day. Yeah.
You guys didn't even talk about this,
but he basically is one of the founders
of creative Commons and this whole
licensing structure for content. Like
what we're saying right now, you know,
this is going to be licensed.
I don't know how,
how's it different ways you
and I as I'm a form right here,
this discussion is going to be licensed
you. Yeah. Okay. I mean, you're,
I think you're licensing it in
a certain way. Okay. So it will,
you have the ability to license it however
you want, right? You could say, hey,
anyone can take this and cut it
up and remix it. Or You could say,
now it's locked down.
Um,
but he helped create this whole licensing
array of like six different licenses.
One says you can do absolutely anything
you want with this and other says you
can share it but you can't make
money off it. There's a handful.
And so the freewill stuff is connected
to how we're dealing with information and
like if you, cause if you,
if you think realistic,
we don't own what we're saying,
we're a part of it, right?
We're a conduit where unique conduit.
So it,
I don't think it aligns with how the
universe works to really be locking down
information.
I think that it makes sense probably
in certain short term business,
but you know, I think we have to
open it up to what's really going on.
What do you mean about like locking
down information like source code,
like classified files like our content,
like music,
like video and now how does this,
how does this connect to determinism
and whether or not you have freewill
because it's a mess.
Are,
are you the creator of your information?
Will,
you are certainly if you put in the work,
like let's say you
decided to write a book.
I mean you put hundreds and hundreds of
hours into this book and edit this book
and then you release the book
and someone says, no, you didn't.
You didn't create that.
You are,
you're a product of determination and
I'm going to just steal your book.
That's intellectual theft.
Intellectual theft is real. It's,
it's certainly real in terms of
like creation of content, right?
If you're a standup comedian and someone
takes your countless hours of work and
steals it,
that's intellectual theft for sure.
And then they try to pawn it off as their
own, through their own selfish needs.
A selfish means.
That's why attribution is the key
part of the creative Commons licensing
structure. Always saying if you come up
with a joke, you know it came from here,
but what if it's a profit? Like say
if you wrote a book and a, I say,
hey, this is a great book
written by Bill Ottman.
Give me five bucks for it and putting it
up on my site and you to it. Fuck that.
I mean, here's the thing, I don't,
somebody makes all the money off of
your book because they have a better
platform to sell your book and
they don't give it to you at all.
And you wrote the book, you spent
all the time, you did all the work.
I would for certain content that
I create completely give it away.
That sounds like a guy who's never written
a book. I've written a book. Did you?
I mean I've, I've written
a lot of content. Yeah. But
have you written, I give away,
I give, I've not published, but the book
that you sell, like if you were an author,
but say if you were,
I'm not saying people should be forced
to do this or I'm just saying that this I
think is how creativity happens.
And I just,
I just don't,
people deserve to make money
on their content. Right.
And you deserve to own your stuff.
But I don't think that that's
actually how the universe works.
And I don't think it's acceptable
to say, Oh, free. You know,
free will doesn't exist. I own
your content. But, um, yeah,
that's why I'm struggling to
see how they're connected.
Because if you're not the originator,
then you're not the owner.
That's a weird argument
because you are the originator.
Stephen King wrote all Steven Qr.
You're the unique conduit.
You are the originator of that specific
configuration of information and you
deserve to be able to do everything you're
saying with it. I'm just saying that,
I don't know. It's complex.
Well, it is complex.
If you're saying that all human beings,
essentially,
all of your actions have been determined
by a lot of factors that are outside of
your control. Whether it's genetics,
again, life experience, education,
all the different factors,
your environment. Um,
is that what's causing you to uh,
put out a fucking brilliant record?
It's part of it, right? But maybe
you have 50, maybe you have 50%,
everything else has 50% or there's weed,
I don't know what the percentages,
but if you're a musician and someone
like Spotify comes along and says,
boot do,
you didn't even make that dude,
so we're just going to put it on Spotify
and make millions and give you pennies.
That's not what I'm advocating.
I'm,
I'm saying [inaudible]
uses the blues died.
Well more than that. More
than that. There's, yeah.
Yeah. This a real plagiarism.
So,
but that doesn't,
that doesn't mean that those aren't great
records. That's true. It is true. Yeah.
I mean, it's a led Zeppelin,
this legit gray area. You know,
I found out this bill Burke called me
up and left us really disturbed message.
He was like really bummed out when
he watched in bill's a musician,
he's a drummer. And when he saw
videos of led Zeppelin music played,
and the band that used to open for led
Zeppelin, we played it on the podcast.
We were like, Holy Shit.
Like they just stole stuff.
They just stole giant chunks
and rifts and you know, and,
and I mean, they made
it better I guess. But,
but yeah, but that's a different
thing than Stephen King's book. Why?
Because Stephen King had
to spend countless hours in
front of his laptop trying
to go over each and every sentence and
each and every paragraph and suck you in
and it, all this work. No, they stole
stuff, dude. They sold certain phrases.
But you think he didn't use
a single phrase anywhere
in any of his books that he
didn't pull from something? We certainly
has. Yeah. He certainly has. Um,
I don't think it's the same though. I
think it's similar led Zeppelin, what?
They also had to spend countless hours
recording that performance to get it to
the level of awesomeness.
That way I heard that wasn't easy to do.
They just did a bitch ass move and they
didn't pay those people. Yeah. If you,
no matter what you should be attributing,
if you're taking ideas,
put in the footnotes,
why does it hurt?
It doesn't make your art worse because
then they'd have to admit they stole the
riff for Stairway to heaven from their
opening band. And then people would go,
what? And then they would
see it. Then they would look
at led Zepplin differently.
But you know, human beings are
fucking severely flawed. Um,
I don't know if I buy that with this,
this idea that you're saying in terms
of like a authors creating content.
I'm not trying to sell something.
No, I know, but if they are,
I don't think someone should be able
to copy their stuff and sell it.
I don't think they should either.
But what do you think they do license?
I think using it should be
able to do you think? Okay,
you should be able to decide. So if you
the content creator, you should. Okay.
I agree with that.
Yeah. Yeah, it's, it is.
I mean obviously I play
devil's advocate a lot,
but that's how you get to the
bottom and these conversations.
But it is a very complicated issue.
The complicated issue of who you are and
why you are who you are and who you are
at this moment versus who you are a
decade ago or two decades ago. It's,
it's all very weird,
you know?
I mean you go back and think about stuff
from high school and you're like, Jesus,
what am I really? Even that person,
like I think about like I've,
I've talked to my sister about stuff that
happened when were in high school. Hey,
you remember that guy? And all he said
to say hi and like I was not even me.
Do I ever know that person? Like
is that really me? Cause I, if I,
if I see them again, I'll
be like, oh yeah. Oh yeah,
we had a 10th grade science
together. Oh yeah. Huh? Crazy.
Like I ran into a guy from my high school
like a couple of weeks ago and it was
weird. It was so weird. You know,
he remembered some strange story from
English class and I was like, wow,
you remember that? Like how weird.
And while he was talking me, I'm like,
is that even really me?
Like,
cause even really talking about me
because I don't have any connection to the
stuff that he's saying. And I
understand that he has, it's vague,
distant ghostlike memory
in his mind of some,
some slide images that he's pieced
together that he recognizes as a,
a past interaction. I
mean, it's fucking strange.